c'est une tranche de vie au féminin
pluriel quand j'ai vu six sections
sportives dans le foot je me suis dit
vas j'aimerais bien tenter ma chance
quand j'étais these mais je pourrais y
jamais y aller dans cette école là quand
on le dit bac tu es sélectionné va sans
rêver israel iz enfants qu une immersion
express en milieu scolaire aux côtés des
ados de la section sportive dans un
petit village du sud manche à bord de l'
des sporades sud il fait les sélections
mais j'avais à peu près le même niveau
que cette fille d'un mixte et mon
intéressant que le de venir ici les
tester dans trois clubs
enfin trois sections différentes et puis
la normandie ça le cadrer tout bas ça
m'a plu un après midi de septembre au
collège pierre aguiton de brécé voilà
dix ans maintenant que le seul
établissement normandie de labellisée
par la fédération française et la ligue
de football compte dans ses rangs aux
côtés des garçons des féminines deux
fois 4e une fois 3e au championnat de
france c'est une belle carte de visite
donc les élèves savent aussi que quand
on va à presser on a une chance de
réussir dans le foot
l'établissement a des résultats
scolaires exceptionnel un climat
scolaire exceptionnel qui fait que les
élèves ici disent qu'ils sont heureux le
bouche à oreille c'est quand même
ce qui se fait ailleurs donc c'est vrai
que le foot féminin où on est on passé à
deux trois filles
maintenant on a un vrai groupe d'une
vingtaine d'élèves et certainement que
ça ne va aller qu'en en seulement 10 en
interne pour la plupart toutes sont
licenciés en club et viennent d'horizons
différents à raison de quatre
entraînements par semaine inclus dans un
planning déjà bien chargé les filles de
brécé font bien plus que courir après le
cuir
il saisit par un départ à 7h30 corp
vient il est 20h45 du coup bas enfin on
n'a pas ce genre n'a pas vraiment de
temps avec notre famille on peut
vraiment les appeler ce qu'apprend doit
rentrer faire de douche préparer nos
affaires du coup bah moi je viens je les
prends du temps serré entre l'amp
luttange du foot et l'internât et et les
cours mais sinon c'est bien parce que ça
nous fait des journées chargées du coup
le sort après avoir bien c'est une leçon
d'autonomie pour les enfants il faut
qu'ils se prennent en charge
il faut qu'il soit bien responsable et
puis c'est un équilibre à trouver on est
toujours en train de jongler sur ses
décors de la entre le travail scolaire
et puis le football
si un peu de fatigue passagère on peut
très bien supprimer un entraînement de
foot mais c'est rarement le cas
on leur ment pas on leur dit dès le
départ que c'est un étude sport et pas
un sport étude que les études passent
avant que peu d'entre elles seront
professionnels le par et pour les
garçons et que du coup il faut assurer
le coût pour les études et si en foot ça
fonctionne c'est du bonus
à l'ombre du sport-études foot garçons
fondée il ya quarante ans les filles de
brécé planche donc à un avenir meilleur
de ces années qui forment le corps et
l'esprit de jeunes ados temple et pense
ouvre belge continue joseph est en bas
j'ai serré 2 de force à un petit peu
mais après elle de la sphère mon métier
je sais pas mais en tout cas quand je
joue ça me fait plaisir et c'est le
principal
je le fonçage comme une de mes passions
mais pour moi le plus important c'est
études pour l'instant on a encore gênée
on a beaucoup à progresser dans la vie
donc si on vient ici c'est pour
progresser je pense en premier
autrement après peut-être qu'il y en a
qui sortiront du lot mais enfin là c'est
difficile à dire
à l'issue de leurs années collège
certaines filles de brécé continueront
assurément à jongler le quotidien entre
études et sport et pourquoi pas à
quelques kilomètres de là sur les carrés
verts de valognes où évoluent les filles
de la section du lycée cornaz
[Musique]